à croquer voilà je reviens toujours pas
si le canard plus tard on va tous mourir
c'est sûr chapka vous enfilez tous les
jours
j'étais moi
c'est parce que j'ai tiré dessus
tiré par unis à l'autre
où est-ce qu'ils sont tous cassés
j'essaye de les appeler mais y'a pas
tonalité ricard toujours bien j'en
attire depuis dix ans peut-être
quelqu'un enlever tous les passants du
coin le fait de penser différemment on
après supposer qu'il ya un fou qui tire
à tout va c'est peut-être autre chose
que tu t'es personnes dans le centre de
madrid
personne ne dit rien la situation est
critique rihanna qui appartient cette
mallette seul touché pas d'atouts que la
ccin est parmi nous et non pas de
nouveau rien
tragédie reconstruit non ce qu'on est en
train de dire c'est qu'on est déjà mort
j'ai peut-être une autre explication
croyez-moi je n'osais rien dire et si on
avait été tous enlevés
[Applaudissements]
j'ai beaucoup aimé ta pub c'était
bientôt à celui du jambon cuit
c'était mon idée bon après il ya un
réalisateur et tout le reste
ouais mais disons que le concept de base
c'est moi tu t'en souviens les enfants
le jambon et le petit mouton les moutons
c'est fin c'est un vrai nom s'était du
3d 3d un dessin c'était vraiment très
bien fait merci ça va être marrant non
de travailler là dedans là je crois pas
de toute façon je ne vais pas faire de
la pub toute ma vie non j'ai des projets
tu vois à oui quel projet
c'est vraiment bête ce que justice des
projets comme si on pouvait avoir des
projets pour ma part j'ai encore plein
de choses à faire
je n'ai pas l'intention de baisser les
bras bien sûr que non non moi dit tout
je ne suis jamais tombé amoureux c'est
simple c'est une chose ok sérieux
vraiment jamais et une fille comme toi
pourtant tu es mais je veux dire en fait
je te connais pas du tout non en fait
c'est vrai